check this out video shows reinstated
Tennessee State Rep Justin Jones
stopping cars and assaulting drivers in
the summer of 2020. this is what I'm
talking about so we were just talking
about this idea of useless people you've
got two trains of thought happening
right now this uh what's Yuval Harare is
that his name
he's talking about these useless eaters
but these are like the Davos group
people who are more you know I don't
know comic book of villainy
but I do think that there may be a
separate perspective on how to deal with
the problem their view I think is dark
the global the Davos group all the stuff
there like you will owe nothing and
you'll be happy my view of dealing with
the useless eaters or whatever it is he
calls them is to provide purpose and
meaning exactly so I look at this story
this story is extremely important
because this is an elected Democrat
State Rep I believe yes State Rep who is
attacking vehicles in the summer of 2020
and then gets elected
to office this guy
reportedly assaulted members of the
Tennessee Tennessee legislature in 2019
throwing coffee at them hot coffee and
was banned from the Capitol Building he
is a violent extremist who now holds a
seat of power and when he was expelled
for joining the Insurrection the
Tennessee Capital they reinstate him I
do not see our system maintaining itself
if these people are taking seats of
power and I warned this would happen in
2018. people told me I was crazy when I
said this stuff will reach the highest
levels of government next stop federal
government and what happens when you
have antifa violent anti-fuck extremists
getting elected to congress which is
already on the horizon I mean AOC is on
the borderline of being a far left
extremist granted she still plays ball
with the establishment but next up the
next four years the next eight years
we're going to start seeing Psychopaths
like this sitting in the Senate and
they're going to be advocating and
defending more violence like this then
the system breaks one of the things and
there's a lot about this story that's
that's shocking but that this story is
only really covered as far as I could
find on the post-millennial if this was
the opposite party it would be not only
Legacy of mainstream media Across
America it would be worldwide news that
is imagine that there was a republican
who was involved in January 6th actually
part of that we would never hear the end
of it they tried making it the narrative
saying that people like Marjorie Taylor
green was giving tours or something
trying to insinuate that there was
pre-planning on behalf of the
Republicans which is all just utter
nonsense but yes if this was any
Republican it would be International and
why don't the Democrats just come out
and condemn it it's simple condemn it
get and then they'll they'll look more
reasonable you know what I think have
you seen kingsman the first one the
movie years ago so the villain is a tech
billionaire who believes the world is
overpopulated so he wants to preserve
all of the wealthy individuals that he
likes and gives them these devices to
protect them and then gives away free
cell phones which when he can press a
button they'll emit a sound that makes
everybody go crazy and kill each other
it's really funny how they make this
movie and this guy is like the Earth is
overpopulated so it's giving itself a
fever and it's killing everybody that's
basically how he talks I'm imitating him
and so the premise of the movie is Tech
billionaire wants to kill billions of
people to save the Earth
then you look at stuff like this and
you're like why is it that you know
these Davos group individuals these
billionaires and these Democrats
don't understand that their policies
destroy cities that they're supporting
violent people why is it that you get a
video of a dude filling a black garbage
bag with products at a Walgreens
and you can't do anything to stop them
it's like because they're on the side of
the villain in the movie Kingsman their
mentality is let the system be destroyed
by itself to save the planet Tim I think
you're onto something quite interesting
there philosophically because most of
the great evils if if not the vast
majority
taken out in the world where people who
philosophically believed they were doing
the right thing the Communist Stalin
thought he was doing the right thing I'm
sure there were Psychopaths amongst them
perhaps Hitler was one the Nazis they
thought they were doing the right thing
and that's how they're able to do such
evil if you believe you're doing in
doing the right thing you can do the
work the absolute unimaginable
atrocities and and I think that analogy
of the kingsman probably asked for that
and that and that's just it these people
they think they're doing good the
useless eaters that that guy describes
this is how he views them and so what
better way to reduce you know the saying
is you are the carbon they are trying to
reduce what better way than let the
system Fall Apart
stop maintaining it let it fall and
you'll cut population down or at least
population growth and I'll put it this
way Bill Gates is a TED Talk where he
says if we work hard enough in these
areas we can reduce population growth by
what do you say like 10 or 15 or
something like that now a lot of people
immediately came out and said he's
talking about reducing population by 10
or 15 percent no no he said population
growth his whole bit publicly is too
many people are coming too fast let's
slow that down but of course that's the
opposite is true by the way well my
point is that position makes no sense
you can't be like we have too many
people let's just have too many people
slower you either think there's too many
people and there should be less of them
or you don't think there's too many
people but continue well the the the
real problem and the thing that I am
most concerned about everything is
population decline that we are we're
going to have an aging population with
and this is happening now and across the
world where uh I think most of the
countries if I'm not mistaken you might
need to fact check me on this and now
population growth is in Decline so even
in in Africa now the uh the average
amount of children per family has gone
from seven to four I say and then and
it's going in that direction what you're
then going to have is uh uh an old
population who are not working having to
be supported by the working population
which is getting smaller and smaller and
smaller and what happens in that that
old people die all people well old
people die but it it continues that
phenomenon continues as the population
of clients in fact Hungary is the only
country in the world that are
implementing policy to encourage mothers
to have more children and that is should
be far more concerning to the elite not
hungry
is that right why would it be concerning
to the people who want less people the
global Elites the people like Bill Gates
Who come out and say there should be
less people are probably happy to hear
that there's less people and I think the
answer to this is very very simple for
anybody who's listening there's two
things you can do everyone says Tim what
can I do I hear about all these bad
things what what is going on here two
very very simple things you can do the
first don't buy Anheuser-Busch products
no more Budweiser no more Bud Light I
think michelob's in there Modelo
shinerbach get it all out of there
figure it out and buy a different beer
brand it sounds absurd but that's true
but more importantly the real point I
was gonna make is have a bunch of babies
what you mentioned 10 babies what you
mentioned is is happening but it's
happening on a grander level in the
western world uh so so populations
aren't replacing the population that uh
is is dying off especially in places
like Europe especially in places like
Japan and these crashes are going to
have significant ramifications not just
for the economy but for society in large
and when you look at the actual numbers
you look at the actual stats we're not
dealing with too many people we're
dealing with a problem that's going to
be very severe because of too little of
people and Elon Musk talks about this
all the time Bill Gates still for some
reason still Klaus Schwab and a lot of
Elites too many people in this world and
when you look at all these kind of soft
policies when you look at policies that
could be described as fifth generational
Warfare especially when it comes to
people not having a family unit
especially when it comes to people
cutting off their reproductive organs
when it comes to people being poisoned
by microplastics or seed oils or
chemicals that are incentivized and of
course paid for by tax subsidies all of
those things correls under situations
and circumstances where people are less
fertile having less babies having less
families and and this is really reaching
a crescendo moment that's going to be
tragic not only for the future
Generations but the future of the earth
which is going to have civilizational
collapse very soon if this is not
addressed and the only country is
addressing it is hungry Poland and China
that I've seen personally we don't need
the government to address it we need
honest moral people with good morals to
just have babies we need both but I also
say there's geopolitical ramifications
as well Louise Perry has just written
about this and unheard at the car
currently South Korea is in massive
population decline North Korea is still
growing so we'll be in a position and I
forget in how many decades but not very
long where North Korea's population will
be twice as much as South Korea they'll
be able to walk in they'll just take
over it's it's it's it's geopolitically
it's a massive issue it's a huge issue
it's going to be tragic it's going to be
absolutely horrible because the
trajectory that we're going on
especially with not just the
reproductive care or abortion but but
more specifically with with testosterone
levels and sperm levels dropping
dramatically to the point where it's
shocking where where people and some
experts are saying we could soon reach a
point in time in our lifetimes where
where males can't reproduce there's a
there's a crazy visualization surge I
don't know if you can pull this up but
it's a if you search Engadget humans in
a pile it's it's basically a
visualization of of what all the humans
if they were just put into a pile would
look like oh like where it's like a big
Mound yeah it's like a big Mound yeah
and it's just you know know there's a
lot of people there's not no but the
point being it's not that much space
Here's oh right right yeah here's here's
here's what I think is is going on I
think these powerful Davos type Elites
don't really care all that much about
too many people they care specifically
about the useless eaters yeah if these
people were all doing functional tasks
then we would have like I'll put it this
way maybe they don't please I don't know
these people seem to be crazy and out of
their minds if every person on this
planet had a specialty and filled the
quota of their uh economic requirement
meaning
let's say Earth could handle you know
100 million uh rocket Engineers if every
single person if every single job and
that was was filled and every single
person was doing a legitimate job that
advanced human civilization we would be
colonizing other planets already we'd be
we'd have warp drive the problem is
large portions of humans on this planet
do nothing and that's what these people
think they become nightmarish despotic
Psychopaths who think let's just get rid
of people where the solution is we
should educate the Next Generation give
them purpose and give them morals and
craft the the uh mechanisms by which
humans become
useful that's actually what they want I
think and what the concern is is the age
of automation is we're entering a fourth
Industrial Revolution now where
artificial intelligence is taking over
people's jobs we'll have less need for
human labor and they are very concerned
about the useless eaters revolting or
losing their mind they don't have enough
this happened with the luddites what
exactly Industrial Revolution people are
like I will not have this and then you
get the luddites people who just oppose
the advancements I I kind of disagree
with you guys I I think they're more of
a destructive force I think they're more
sociopathic I think they're more
deranged than you guys give them credit
to because even if everyone was was
productive and had a purpose and had a
belief system and all that I I think
throughout human history there have
always been a group of individuals or
one individual trying to take control of
the entire world I think this is what
it's really about at the end of the day
I think it's about control I think it's
about enslavement no matter what we do
they're always going to be there is
always going to be a group of
sociopathic individuals trying to
control everything for themselves either
for demonic reasons sure
now we'll stop and ask ourselves
what is going through their mind if that
is the case what is their goal and what
is their desire is their desire
something as one-dimensional as I just
want to control things or is their goal
something like I want there's eternal
life there's a there's another aspect to
it I think this applies to Davis Davos
it's the banality banality of evil which
is that you have for example Davos you
have a lot of politicians who are
thinking what am I going to do after I
I'm kicked out of office I need a
high-paying job and then you have a lot
of the corporates who are there who have
a ton of money but don't have the power
that the politicians have so they want
to be there so they have their own
individual personal Ambitions which is
driving them there they might not be
thinking how do I control the world they
are some of them I'm sure are thinking
that but I think a lot of them are
thinking how do I make my life better
and so they go along with what ends up
being evil uh
sort of phenomenon of the evil uh groups
like that I have a feeling if we do
create purpose and productivity that it
will take some of the burden off of
Klaus Schwab's mind because I I don't
look at him as like a a violent
psychopath that wants to burn I think
they're trying to prevent World War III
and they're desperate and so they're
like put them in pods I don't know what
what but it doesn't matter
the doubt at the very least I disagree
look at this guy attacking the motorist
right this guy thinks he's stopping
world war three this guy thinks he's
stopping climate change but he's clearly
a deranged psychopath who's doing
nothing but attacking random innocent
motorists yeah now Cloud Schwab's no
different yeah he thinks he's doing good
but what he doesn't maybe he doesn't
know or he's taking a risk on is it
centralizing Authority has never really
worked on the human but it has always
been something that many people have
tried to achieve throughout human
history and no matter how many people
they slaughter and enslave that is
always their end goal and has always
been their end goal and to think that
this doesn't exist now when it existed
all throughout human history is very
naive because now with the technology
now with so much power with so much
influence it's so much wealth
concentrated against so many few
individuals they have an abundant amount
of resources they have Quantum Computing
they have artificial intelligence they
have new technology that could
essentially help them live forever while
everyone else is going to be of course
enslaved to this system that they're
building all around us and when we look
at what they're incentivizing and we
look at what they they're attacking what
are they attacking they're attacking
religion they're attacking purpose
they're attacking labor they're
attacking the middle class they're
attacking any human beings being
productive doing the good things what
are they incentivizing social justice
Warrior woke causes like this they're
incentivizing a divide and conquer
agenda that has people fighting each
other they're in incentivizing system
that is essentially order out of chaos
and creating this horrible situation
where we're fighting each other and not
even having real deep discussions about
how big the rabbit hole goes and who's
really in charge because they don't want
to be challenged exactly you're right
about the control but I think they're
more like the villain from Kingsman they
want people to erase themselves yeah my
question though and they are who's they
I mean it's kind of tongue-in-chief
exactly like clouds okay maybe has one
motive but Xi Jinping as another motive
and Joe Biden's has a motive and and
Putin together like maybe one of them is
a violence like Mafia crime families but
they understand that if one family or if
something else threatens the the
alliance or the game that they're
playing playing that they take them out
so when you look at everything it's it's
multiple factors it's it's multiple
organizations working together and they
have a shared goal and obviously
sometimes they fight within each other
but they always make sure that the game
continues and the game is rigged against
you one of the uh reasons that they I
that the problems they identify are for
example not poverty but inequality or
let's say it's the environmental crisis
is because those are issues that cannot
be solved the problems that they
identified that cannot be solved from
the ground up rather that we need to
hand over our power to the technocrats
they and that's maybe where the power
thing comes into play that I think I
probably agree with you as they're
funneling and fueling the problems look
at what George Soros and how much money
he's throwing at District Attorneys what
has been the cause of George Soros
spending about a million dollars on
every district attorney what has
happened thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at pm
and become a member over at timcast.com
for uncensored members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time